wer von diesem Tag Zeichen für einen
Ausweg aus dem brutalen Krieg erwartete
wurde enttäuscht US-Präsident beiden am
Abend in Warschau groß inszeniert vor
dem Königsschloss seine Rede sehr
symbolisch die NATO stünde fest an der
Seite Kies sie verteidigten gemeinsam
die Freiheit und ein Ende des Tötens
Liga allein in der Macht Moskau
der Krieg ist keine Notwendigkeit er ist
eine Tragödie Präsident Putin hat diesen
Krieg gewählt jeden Tag geht dieser
Krieg weiter er hat die Wahl er könnte
den Krieg mit einem Wort beenden es ist
einfach
zuvor am Vormittag in Moskau Putins
redet zur Lage der Nation die Weltsicht
desjenigen der der Ukraine den Krieg
aufgezwungen hat der Westen habe Schuld
er wolle eine globale Konfrontation in
den Untergang Russlands es verteidige
sich in der Ukraine die russische Armee
sei nicht zu besiegen
wir bekämpfen nicht das ukrainische Volk
das habe ich schon oft gesagt das Volk
der Ukraine ist eine Geisel des Regimes
in Kiew und seiner westlichen Herrscher
die das Land politisch militärisch und
wirtschaftlich besetzt haben
kein Wort zu einem möglichen Ende des
Krieges kein Wort zum Angebot Chinas
diplomatische Lösungen auszuloten
konkret kündigte Putin an dass
sogenannte new start Abkommen mit den
USA aussetzen zu wollen es begrenzt die
Anzahl von nuklearen Sprengköpfen und
abschlusseinrichtungen auf beiden Seiten
im Endeffekt sehe ich die Rede so dass
sie das eher Russland auf einen
langfristigen Krieg gegen den Westen
einschwört und dieses Element mit dem
new start Suspendierung ist ein Zeichen
dafür dass es ein langer Krieg und
langer Konflikt werden wird und das
Russland kein Interesse an der
Eskalation und vor allen Dingen kein
Interesse an diplomatischen Lösungen hat
Chinas Chef Diplomat traf gestern in
Moskau Putin Sicherheitsberater bei der
betonten die Enge ihrer Partnerschaft
aber auch hier kein Wort zu einem Ausweg
aus dem Krieg
schalten wir zunächst zu unserem
usa-korrespondenten Elmar tbwissen der
den US-Präsidenten in Warschau begleitet
schönen guten morgen noch mal Elmar wie
besorgt sind denn die USA das Putin den
Abrüstungsvertrag new start aussetzen
will
mein Eindruck ist sie sind nicht zu
besorgt wir hatten gestern Abend gleich
in einem Nebenraum hier Gelegenheit mit
ganz engen Beratern von Joe Biden zu
sprechen wir dürfen ihre Namen nicht
nennen aber alles was Sie uns sagen
natürlich verwenden und sie sagten uns
dass diese Ankündigung von Putin
eigentlich nur die Realität
widerspiegelt wie sie seit mehr als
sechs Monaten ist seitdem Lars lässt
Russland keine Inspektoren mehr an die
Atomwaffen in Russland heran beteiligt
sich auch nicht mehr an den
Konsultationen die eigentlich
pflichtmäßig vorgeschrieben sind während
gleichzeitig russische Inspektoren
Zugang in den USA haben die USA haben
genau dieses schon seit drei Wochen
öffentlich gemacht diesen Bruch des
Vertrages insofern wird das hier eher
als ein Zeichen der Schwäche gesehen
diese Ankündigung bei Putin damit
beweist dass er null Interesse an Dialog
hat auch in seiner sonstigen Rede war ja
irgendwo ein Anhaltspunkt dafür dass er
von seinen maximalzielen abweichen will
insofern richtet man sich auf einen
langen Konflikte ein immer der
US-Präsident ist weiter in Polen ich
heute mit osteuropäischen NATO-Staaten
in Warschau worum wird es da vor allem
gehen
ja es geht in erster Linie um die
Stärkung der Ostflanke also inwieweit
ist man im Osten der NATO aufgestellt
mit Soldaten mit entsprechend
Rüstungsgütern Koordination und
Absprachen Jens Stoltenberg der
Nato-Generalsekretär ist dabei und
besonders spannend Viktor Orban der
Premierminister Ungarns der
amerikanische Präsident hat ja gestern
gesagt die Welt steht am Scheideweg man
muss sich entscheiden zwischen der Regel
und wertebasierten Ordnung auf der einen
und dem Autoritarismus auf der anderen
Seite und Viktor Orban wird ja eine Nähe
zu Wladimir Putin nachgesagt er selber
vertritt etwas was er
illiberale Demokratie nennt im Grunde
genommen einen autoritäres System und
insofern stellen sich hier viele Fragen
in die weit Ungarn wirklich ein
verlässlicher Partner in der Ostflanke
der NATO ist Matthias live aus Warschau
vielen Dank Elmar der und auch in der
Ukraine haben viele natürlich genau
zugehört was die beiden Präsidenten
gesagt haben nur ein paar Tage vor dem
Jahrestag des russischen Angriffs auf
die Ukraine
zum Studios jetzt der Botschafter der
Ukraine in Deutschland olixiev schönen
guten Morgen guten Morgen herr
botschaftliche Präsident selenski hat
sich noch gar nicht geäußert jetzt nach
diesen beiden reden wie reagieren sie
nachdem was Putin gesagt hat und was
beiden gesagt hat das sind zwei
verschiedene Welten was was Putin gesagt
hat erinnert mich an an George Orwells
1984 Krieg ist Frieden
Lüge ist Wahrheit und Freiheit des klar
ist Sklaverei einen eine kriegstreibende
Rede und man sieht dass das Putin
niemanden mit einbezieht in die
Entscheidungen und dass die ganze Welt
des klar sieht dass das Putin
verhandlungsunfähig ist und diesen Krieg
weiter verfolgen wird im Unterschied zu
putin war die Rede von Präsident beiden
in Warschau Rede eines Präsidenten der
für die ganze Welt spricht und die ganze
Welt rund um Ukraine konsolidiert wenn
man präsent Putin zugehört hat hatte man
das Gefühl dass dieser Krieg noch sehr
lange dauern könnte und man hat den
Eindruck dass die Sorgen in der Ukraine
größer werden ob man diesem lang
anhaltenden Krieg standhalten kann es
fehlen Munition es fehlt Material es
gibt berichtet dass sie nicht genug
Freiwillige haben also wie sehr stehen
sie unter Druck in der Ukraine und wie
bewerten sie derzeit die militärische
Situation man vergisst dass wir in der
Ukraine schon seit 9 Jahren unter Druck
stehen und diese Krise seit neue Jahr
waren Russland führt und nach der
Invasion vor einem Jahr haben wir
Ukraine der ganzen Welt klar gezeigt
dass wir uns verteidigen können wir
können es besser machen wenn uns
geholfen wird und dazu ist eine
riesenkoalition gebildet und
Deutschland trägt auch dazu bei dass wir
notwendige Waffen und auch Munition
bekommen Deutschland trägt bisher mit
Kampfpanzern dazu beide Ukraine fordert
auch Kampfflugzeuge diese Diskussion
wird auch schon geführt und eine
Forderung des ukrainischen
vize-regierungschefs auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz ließ aufhorchen
erforderte vom Besten Streu Munition und
phosphorbrandwaffen obwohl beides
völkerrechtlich geächtet ist will die
Ukraine diesen Weg gehen wir haben es
gesehen dass Russland in der Ukraine
verschiedene Arten von Waffen benutzen
und auch Streu Munition leider benutzt
Russland Strom Munition auch gegen
Zivilbevölkerung wir gehen einfach davon
aus dass wir jede mögliche Waffe zur
Verfügung stehen muss damit wir uns
verteidigen können aber ich bin mir
sicher dass Waffen in der Ukraine auf
keinen Fall gegen Zivilbevölkerung
benutzt wird stellt sich ja immer wieder
die Frage wie eine automatische Lösung
aussehen kann nach den beiden Reden
gestern liegt das ja in weiter Ferne sie
kennen aber hier in Deutschland die
Initiative Manifest für den Frieden
Sahra Wagenknecht war vor einer Stunde
bei uns in der Sendung und sie plädiert
dafür den Frontverlauf einzufrieren zu
verhandeln und die Menschen in den von
Russland besetzten Gebieten im Osten
ihres Landes abstimmen zu lassen was
halten Sie davon
Frau wagt nicht sagt auch eigenen
Wählern das eigentlich wenn sie
angegriffen werden auf der Straße oder
wenn jemand ins Haus eindringt oder wenn
jemand eine deutsche Frau oder deutsche
Kinder vergewaltigt da sagt Frau
Wagenknecht bitte keine Polizei anrufen
in Verhandlungen gehen
da braucht Deutschland keine Polizei
weil für für Frau Wagenknecht sind die
genau verstanden
vielleicht zur Frage ja Frontverlauf
einfrieren ich kann ja verstehen dass
sie sich das nicht nicht vorstellen
können aber der Vorwurf glaube ich
lautet das und das hat sie auch in der
Sendung gesagt dass die Ukraine erst
verhandeln will wenn der letzte
russische Soldat von der Krim
verschwunden ist und auf der einen Seite
kann man ihren Standpunkt ja als
souveränes Land verstehen auf der
anderen Seite ist es ja schon so wenn
Sie den Konflikt jetzt einfrieren würden
verhandeln würden könnten Menschen leben
gerettet werden könnten Menschen leben
gerettet werden wie gesagt diese Krieg
ist etwas sehr weit entfernt auch von
deutschen Fernseh zu schauen stellen
sich vor es geht um um ihre eigene
Wohnung und diese Verhandlungen werden
in Ihrem Wohnzimmer geführt und die
Kinder werden weiter hier vergewaltigt
was wäre dann verhandlungsvorschlag
Friedensverhandlungen sehen so aus in
der Ukraine der Kerl ist mit seinen
Truppen in unserem Wohnzimmer er
vergewaltigt er tötet er bringt die
Kinder aus unserer Wohnung Weg nach
Russland verschleppt unsere Kinder und
Frau Wagenknecht möchte mit ihm
verhandeln da wäre sie gut beraten wenn
dann am Samstag hier am Brandenburger
Tor die Parolen Russland raus aus der
Ukraine klingen und nicht nur
Friedensverhandlungen das müsste
Frau Wagenknecht und diejenigen die sich
für Frieden einsetzen klar auch dem
Putin und den Russen sagen raus aus der
Ukraine stoppt diesen Krieg aber was ist
die Alternative
es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass jetzt
in absehbarer Zeit sich Russland
zurückziehen wird aus dem Ortsgebieten
und vor allem von der Krim vor einem
Jahr war es für viele unwahrscheinlich
das Russland
zurückzieht aus Kiew und alle haben
gedacht Ukraine ja ja das das Ukraine in
drei Tagen schon fällt wir Ukraine haben
es gezeigt dass wir haben viel Mut und
wir können uns verteidigen deswegen wir
werden es auch weiterhin machen und
bitte glauben Sie an die Ukraine wir
sind ein kämpferisches Volk und es geht
ums Überleben deswegen kämpfen wir um
unsere Freiheit und wir erkämpfenden
Frieden in Europa und das in zwei Tagen
schon seit einem Jahr vielen Dank für
das Interview das war der Botschafter
der Ukraine in Deutschland olexesh
herzlichen Dank Herr Botschaft danke
schön